Ist es ihr wirklich egal?
Beim Besuch eines Heims für Kinder illegaler
Einwanderer an der Grenze zu Mexiko
sorgt First Lady Melania Trump für Aufsehen -
aber
weniger mit ihrem dortigen Auftritt, sondern mit der Jacke,
die sie auf dem Weg dorthin
trägt.
Beim Besteigen des Flugzeugs in Richtung Texas
trägt Melania einen Parka mit der Aufschrift:
"I really don't care. Do u?"
– zu deutsch: "Es ist mir völlig egal. Und Dir?"
Online sorgt der Spruch für allerlei Gesprächsstoff.
Sind die Migrantenkinder der First Lady egal?
Hat sie das falsche Teil im Schrank gegriffen?
Ist es eine versteckte Botschaft?
Melanias Sprecherin widerspricht den Spekulationen
– die Medien sollten sich auf den Besuch
der First Lady an der US-Grenze, anstatt auf
ihre Jacke fokussieren.
Eine versteckte Botschaft gebe es nicht.
US-Präsident Donald Trump nimmt seine Ehefrau
ebenfalls in Schutz: Der Spruch beziehe sich
auf die Fake-News-Medien, twitttert Trump.
"Melania hat gelernt, wie unehrlich sie sind,
und es ist ihr inzwischen wirklich egal!"
Die Jacke soll ein preisgünstiges Modell
von der Stange sein - an sich ungewöhnlich
für das frühere Model, das gerne exquisite
Garderobe trägt.
Auch das trägt zu den anhaltenden Spekulationen
bei.
Zumal es nicht das erste Mal ist, dass Melania
Trump mit ihrer Kleiderwahl für Stirnrunzeln
sorgt. 2017 stakste sie auf extrem hochhackigen
und dünnen Stöckelschuhen durch das texanische
Houston, um die vom Hurrikan "Harvey" angerichteten
Verwüstungen zu besichtigen.